hey heather what's up hey oh my gosh
thank you gentlemen for taking my call
it's such an honor to speak to both of
you today
you too how can we help awesome um
so um i have actually instead of gone
backwards in pay i was able to double my
income
in this past year wow um yeah i'd
finally
you know make the six figure mark which
i had a lifelong goal of hitting before
i hit 35 and finally hit that at 36 but
hey
for you yes what do you do thank you so
much
um i am a medical scientist for clinical
research
so i look at clinical trial data thank
you
thank you so much um but with that comes
from challenges that i'm trying to face
and i'm hoping to get some advice
so i'm married we've been married for
about nine years we have two small kids
and my husband still wants to keep
everything
separate and i'm trying to get us you
know
out of debt um i currently have
a nice you know student loan chunk of 92
000
and some personal stuff that i'm trying
to get rid of um
but he just doesn't want to get on board
and instead wants to keep it separate so
i have absolutely no idea
what's going on on his end of things so
i'm wondering can i do
this baby step number two by myself now
that i have my bigger shovel
or you know how can i get my husband on
board because
now that i make essentially double what
he does he's having a hard time with it
so i don't know how to handle it
why am i not shocked um
what does he do for a living oh he's
military
okay all right yeah uh what does he do
in the military
um he is um he's active duty so
yeah yeah he's active duty in the army
okay uh just infantry is that what
you're saying or he doesn't have a
specialty inside the military
uh no he's uh special forces okay all
right good
yeah yeah so he does a lot of stressful
high intense
stuff and yeah
[Music]
um yeah
this is a marriage problem this is a
marriage problem it's a marriage problem
it's not a financial problem
and um uh and
uh the chances of this guy that you
described to me going to a marriage
counselor is probably fairly low
um but that's what you guys need you
need someone to
help you navigate your pastor at your
church could serve the purpose if he's
he or she's got some counseling chops
but to sit down with someone to help you
guys navigate through
all the different variables that are
happening in your relationship
you making more his uh incredible
intense job
uh what it is that's causing him to want
to keep the money separate
why does it need to be separate what's
he afraid of
uh so i've made some you know bad money
decisions which
racked up some debt but i'm working
through that you know i just paid off my
car two years early
this weekend how long ago did you make
bad money decisions
um so um
let's see i guess since we've kind of
been dating i'm a big impulse
spender i mean how long ago was your
last bad
money decision um over a year
over a year ago yeah okay all right
so maybe part of you all combining this
is for you to be accountable
yeah which i'm totally fine with you
know that's kind of why i want him on
board like i want to be held accountable
i want him to say hey do you really need
that trip to target you know
200 toothpaste well we have a budget
that we have agreed to before
our month begins and it would include
target only to a certain amount
and anything past that you would be
breaking your contract with him
yeah which i'm fine doing yeah yeah is
he very conservative with his money does
he have any debt
uh he does have some debt he just bought
a new truck last year
um and i know he's got a credit card
but he's been a lot better with money he
had a bunch better money school than i
did growing up um
but i mean other than those two things
that i know about i don't know
about the other stuff all right you know
i see stuff come in and
let me tell you here's the date the data
points are this okay
um
[Music]
guys and gals that do what he does uh
they face death in the
eye uh fairly regularly
and so they have a tendency to detach
it's a it's a normal defense mechanism
um
and uh it's very very tough
to be the spouse of special forces
um until they really get their arms
around
uh all the emotions that they feel
and plug those into your relationship
it's a very tough thing we do a lot of
work with special forces i
i think these are some of the best
people on the planet they're incredible
but
they do things and see things that none
of the rest of us can do
or ever see and so it just is a
different world
and um but that doesn't change the data
the data tells us that couples
who do not work together on money have a
higher
uh problem rate in their marriage and a
higher divorce rate
and have a lower chance of actually
building wealth
the do it separately and be roommates
thing almost never works relationally
or financially and so he's barking up
the wrong tree
it's not gonna work it's bad tactics for
the mission would be the phrase i would
use to him
okay the tactics that he has laid out
for this particular mission
suck the mission's going to fail and the
mission is
life and marriage
and wealth building and the tactic that
he's using
is a defense mechanism it is not a
it's not an offensive proper tactic
that's how i would talk to him and you
can play this back for him if you want
to i don't care
because i love the guy i love what he
does i love it i love that i'm free
because of men
like him and so yeah so i
yeah absolutely yeah i'm you know i
appreciate him
but i don't appreciate the way he's
treating his wife
and i uh and you gotta your your part in
this is you're gonna have to stop the
stupid stuff
and you're going to step into the
accountability and use your newfound
income and if you can get him to the
table your newfound cooperation to
really make some serious strides forward
so
we're going to help we're going to
salute you in your new uh
promotion and we're going to salute him
because we appreciate what he does for
this country we're going to give you
ramsey plus for a year which puts the
two of you into
financial peace university together
every dollar budgeting app together
and uh if you guys will watch those
videos together
and start i think it will cause him to
come to the table possibly
and start doing these things together
i'm challenging him to do that
um you know i need him to man up here as
as and walk with his wife not just throw
her in the ditch and hope she makes it
you know you did something stupid like
for a while and i don't trust you so you
just
wallow over there in the ditch by
yourself good luck with that
you know that's just not that's not
manning up and so
um you know walk with your wife for
richer for poorer
in sickness and in health until thee all
my worldly goods
i pledge those are the old-fashioned
marriage vows